Let's try the loop for just the first line first. It seems like the minute
isn't changing, only the hour is changing, so I'll declare a loop variable
called hour that's going to go through all of the hours. It will start at one,
and will go as long as hour is less than or equal to twelve, and we won't skip
any. Inside, I want to print the hour, followed by a colon, followed by the
minute. And I don't want to print it on a line because all of the hours should
go on the same line. Hopefully, you notice I'm using a descriptive name for the
counter. And that's because in a moment we're going to have multiple loops and
it'll be confusing to see which loop counter is which. let's try this and see
how far we got -if I fix the compiler errors. Okay, this is a good start. We
have the first line. Now, the loop for the second line would look like this.
The only difference is this number, the minute. So, I'm going to add a loop
that counts up the minutes. The minutes will go from 0 to 59. And for each
minute, I'll print out all of the possible hours with the current minute. Which
I'll pass into print def so I can get rid of my comparison code down here. And
let's see how that worked. Well, it's kind of hard to tell, because it's all on
one line. What I really want is to have a line break after I finish the first
line. So after I've printed out all of the hours, I want to print an empty line
to advance down to the next line. And now my table prints out, but there are a
couple of issues here. It only goes up to 58 and I said it should go up to 59.
And it looks like some is missing up at the top. The stuff that was missing at
the bottom Is because of my loop condition. I should have gone to less than or
equals and the parts that I'm missing at the top are. Probably because bluej
has limited the amount of output that it remembers in the terminal. I'm
going to try to going to options and unlimited buffering and then try this
again. Now it actually saves all of the data that I wanting to see. Alright, I
think we're already for another practice question.